hey BuzzFeed a showgirl amber okay hey
just living baby and here's a little bit
about me
amber Wagner aka just living baby came
faintly pretty inspirational videos I've
noticed that she's kind of been hard on
yourself you feel me right now I want
you to take a minute and thank your damn
self hug yourself if you can you feel me
Pat show damn stuff on the back I grew
up in a two-parent home with my mother
and father Inglewood California
I'm very get out loud I was playing
double dutch walking to the corner store
eating too much you know kid stuff I
always had an outgoing bubbly
personality up always loud always
rambunctious clumsy as hell just me
while I got in the Instagram in 2014 and
I just started it there with just
regular pictures then one day I had did
a video about my egg my ex get back with
me you notices in that went viral then I
did a video off of Beyonce song drunken
love I've been drinking water then [ __ ]
me toe the [ __ ] the first time I
realized that this could be something
big was when the shade room had it post
me on their page after that celebrity
star posted me they started following me
and I was like okay this is serious now
what made me want to be motivational was
just my life I was in a dark place for a
while you know dealing with these guys
using and abusing me and then me just
not really fully loving myself and
knowing who I was and once I did I don't
know it's a sense just came over me like
you know what you need to put this out
there my mother is like my biggest
inspiration motivator and everything
because that woman is just so strong
like she has been through so much from
hip surgery
shoulder surgery everything feel helping
my grandfather who was bedridden
brushing his teeth making his meals and
she still remains conscious
still remains happy still just does her
best at first when I started social
media she told
you're not funny nobody's gonna like you
I'm like okay and I was crying I was so
sad next thing you know I showed her I
was gonna shave room and I showed her
when Rihanna was following me other
people then she made an Instagram now
she loves it she wears my t-shirt out in
public people saying oh my god you know
her she's like yes that's my daughter
okay so when I'm in my song getting
ready to my videos I'm usually at my
desk
okay I have my phone here and I have to
get my mind right so I think of a topic
for instance heartbreak salt in my head
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] okay I dog and I shout
whatever so I'm like okay let me get
ready I usually you know know me put my
glasses on I'm in my song so hey
Valentine's Day is tomorrow I'm single
and i neva trippin it's okay I just
speak like you know about Who I am and
situations that I've been through and
you know me being like plus-sized I want
to help the plus-sized young ladies and
people ask me how do I do it I say I
just honestly what I did I just spray
about and I'll just keep going
everything it's pure it's nothing forced
the message that I would like to stand
two younger females of color is embrace
yourself don't base how other people
feel about you how you feel about
yourself don't let anybody see rewrite
you tear you from what you're doing just
keep being you you are the mother
[Music]
Oh
[Music]